bonsoir en s'asseyant dans ce fauteuil
monsieur chirac vient de battre un
record
il participe en effet pour la cinquième
fois à l'heure de vérité et il est le
seul dans son cas monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez été le dernier invité
de la précédente législature et vous
êtes le premier de législature qui
s'ouvre et vous venez dans ce studio le
jour même où commence sous votre
impulsion le démantèlement de l'état
patron qui quoi qu'il arrive marquera
une date dans l'histoire de la société
française
lorsque vous êtes passés ici c'était en
1982 en 1983 1985 et en février dernier
vous étiez dans l'opposition
vous disiez vos critiques vous disiez
vos impatiences vos projets aujourd'hui
tout a changé
vous êtes au pouvoir et vous avez les
moyens de concrétiser vos promesses
alors les français attendent donc de
vous des actes des actes et des
explications sur ce que vous avez fait
depuis votre entrée à matignon il ya
tout juste un mois
car et vous le savez mieux que moi
gouverner de nos jours c'est communiquer
c'est gagner la confiance des gens qu'on
dirige alors rares sont les hommes
politiques qui n'ont pas un jour dans un
réflexe d'agacement reprochés au
journaliste qui était face à eux deux
mâles présenter leurs actions
et bien c'est un risque que vous courez
pas ce soir puisque vous allez vous même
vous expliquer en direct sans miroir
déformant sur ce que vous faites est sûr
pourquoi vous le faites
alors il y a bien sûr parmi tous les
sujets actuels des sujets sur lesquels
les français souhaitent plus
particulièrement des éclaircissements et
qui sait peut-être des confidences
inédites
alors quels sont ils ces sujets la
sofres vient de demander par minitel à
l'échantillon qu'elle a sélectionnés
spécialement pour l'heure de vérité
et voici les thèmes qui intéressent le
plus les français qui ont été tes les
sondés il y à quelques minutes alors en
tête et ça ne vous surprendra pas vos
objectifs en matière d'emploi 53% en
deuxième position le programme
votre gouvernement de 41 % suivi de très
près à 40% par les explications sur les
mesures que vous venez de prendre depuis
un mois et vous constaterez tout de
suite que le transfert des télévisions
publiques au secteur privé ne
passionnent pas les français 20%
quand l union rpr udf elvia largement
que avec 12 % seulement des intérêts
alors à vous maintenant évidente parce
qu'elle accueille donc peut-être bon
alors à vous de jouer maintenant mais
c'est le prix ministre en répondant aux
questions particulièrement acérée de
d'alain duhamel de philippe alexandre
bertel d'albert du roi et de jean-luc de
scène qui va vous poser la première
question au nom des téléspectateurs
avoue jean-louis le scène de jacques
chirac bonsoir beaucoup de questions ici
svp pour la première grande émission
politique télévisé depuis que vous avez
été nommé premier ministre
bien sûr les téléspectateurs vous
interroge sur votre politique économique
et sociale le chômage les retraites
beaucoup de questions sur les retraites
sur la chasse aux sorcières dans
l'audiovisuel beaucoup vous questionne
sur la dégradation des relations france
etats-unis après le raid sur la limite
mais au delà de la politique je voudrais
commencer par des fiches qui ont un
caractère plus personnel cela fait plus
d'un mois maintenant que vous cohabiter
avec françois mitterrand vous
personnellement
première question un téléspectateur vous
ne connaissiez pas l'homme françois
mitterrand il ne connaissait pas l'homme
chirac est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
connaissez autres fiches quand vous vous
rencontrez tête à tête vous donnez-vous
toujours du monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
enfin dernière question est ce que la
france serait gouverné la même façon si
vous étiez vous à l'elysée et françois
mitterrand à matignon c'est un peu de la
politique fiction ni cas sur rhône en
tout cas elle aussi pendant toute la
campagne
j'ai dit et je les ai répétés le jour
même de ma nomination que la france
était un pays qui avait une constitution
et que celle ci devait être appliquée le
président la république lorsqu'il l'a
s'est adressée par son message au
parlement a dit la constitution toute la
constitution rien que la constitution
à partir de là ce n'est plus un problème
de rapport personnel c'est un problème
objectif si chacun respecte les
institutions de notre pays le
gouvernement gouverne et il n'y a pas de
problème je dois dire que jusqu'ici il
m'apparaît que chacun a eu à coeur dans
la majorité comme dans l'opposition de
respecter les institutions de notre pays
c'est la loi de la démocratie et de la
république
est-ce qu'on peut travailler ensemble
quand on a comme seul lien à partir de
la constitution à partir du moment où on
respecte la règle fondamentale pour un
pays qui est sa constitution oui bien
alors alain duhamel pour un quart
d'heure
bonsoir à linge halak le premier nice à
ce que dans le cadre de la cohabitation
vous avez demandé au président la
république de vous regarder ce soir
le président de la république est tout à
fait libre de son temps et je n'ai pas
dû suggéré son emploi du temps bon vous
êtes vous occuper vos fonctions depuis
un mois en fait et il ya déjà eu une
épreuve internationale qui est la sphère
du raid aérien américain
alors le non survol de l'hexagone par
les bombardiers américains a suscité
beaucoup de prises de position publiques
virulente notamment deux celle du
président reagan qui a critiqué avec 13
beaucoup fermeté la france est celle du
colonel kadhafi qui en revanche la
féliciter ce que ça vous embarrasse pas
d'être critiqué par reagan est félicité
par kadhafi d'une présentation des
choses un peu rapide
ristic personne ne peut sérieusement
mettre en cause ni la volonté du
gouvernement français de mettre tout en
oeuvre pour lutter contre le terrorisme
d'où qu'il vienne et notamment lorsqu'il
est soutenu par tel ou tel état
la libye dans le cas particulier il en
est d'autres
personne ne peut mettre non plus en
cause la solidarité profonde que ressent
le gouvernement français à l'égard de
ses alliés en général et de son allié
américain en particulier pour des
raisons à la fois historique et de
respect en commun d'un certain nombre de
valeurs qui sont celles des démocraties
occidentales
donc il n'ya pas lieu d'imaginer qu'il
puisse y avoir je ne sais quel
malentendus entre eux simplement nous
avons une politique étrangère qui est
indépendante et nous voulons pouvoir
juger des conséquences des actions que
nous menons
merci a pas de malentendu entre paris
washington pourquoi est ce que le
président reagan a dit en plus c'était
vraiment son initiative il a convoqué
des correspondants de presse
pourquoi est ce qu'il a dit qu'il ne
comprenait pas la position de la france
qui lui vous qui vous n'y voyez pas
d'explication et bien nous nous n'aurons
aucune peine à nous en expliquer j'aurai
l'occasion de rencontrer le président
reagan prochainement à tokyo le
gouvernement vous le savez a décidé de
faire en sorte que la coordination des
actions des démocraties occidentales
comme le souhaitait à juste titre les
américains en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme soit renforcée nous en
discuterons à tokyo et je suis sûr que
sur ce point nous trouverons un terrain
d'entente sans difficulté est-ce que les
motifs de la décision française parce
que c'est passablement la vôtre c'est
aussi celle du président la république
est-ce que les motifs de la décision
française c'est d'abord le sort de nos
huit otages au liban ou pas nous sommes
chacun le comprend je dirai pas ce qu
obsédé par la sphère de nos otages qu'il
s'agisse des quatre je l'espère quatre
qui sont depuis longtemps privés de leur
liberté ou qu'il s'agisse equiland et
vos confrères d'antenne 2 nous en
parlons peu et je souhaite qu'on en
parle le moins possible car plus on en
parle
et puis on renforce le comportement des
terroristes qui les détiennent et qui se
croient tout permis en voyant quelque
sorte l'émotion qu'il provoque chez dans
l'opinion publique française tout
entière qui est solidaire des familles
des otages mais nous faisons tout je
peux vous dire qu'il n'est pas deux
jours depuis que j'ai été nommé premier
ministre
sans que je n'ai à m'occuper de ce
problème des otages et là il a pesé
je ne ferai pas de commentaire sur ce
point je considère que moins on en fait
et mieux ça vaut le problème de fond
était différent nous avons été alertés
quelques heures avant qu'une décision à
prendre et nous avons considéré que nous
qui assumons déjà depuis longtemps
les la pression libyenne au tchad nous
qui avons très clairement indiqué aux
autorités libyennes que notre réaction
serait sans faiblesse et dans tous les
domaines si nous mêmes ou nos alliés
notamment du sud de l'europe ou
l'afrique du nord je pense en
particulier à la tunisie que notre
réaction serait d'une fermeté très très
grande
je crois que nous n'avons pas nous ne
pouvons pas être soupçonnée dans ce
domaine nous voulons simplement jugé au
pourquoi de la nature pourquoi ce que
les américains ne comprennent pas parce
que c'est vrai fa vous le reconnaissez
sûrement qu'il ya en ce moment une
campagne de protestation importantes aux
états unis et qui est un peu un
mouvement anti français oui monsieur
duhamel mais les américains devraient
peut-être observé un phénomène beaucoup
plus important et dont les emplois dont
les autorités françaises ne sont pas
absentes dans ce comportement
c'est le fait que la france est le seul
pays où il n'y a pas eu de
manifestations de masse très importante
et même pas du tout de manifestations
pour condamner le raid américain vous
avez vu ce qui s'est passé en allemagne
en angleterre en italie
dans d'autres pays aussi eu des
manifestations spontanées pour condamner
les américains par en france vous tous
ceux qui éprouvent en clair que la
france en réalité si elle veut conduire
sa politique jugée de ce qu'elle doit
faire
lorsqu'elle prend un engagement est un
pays en réalité comme le général le
général de gaulle avait toujours
souligné dont la solidarité et la
fiabilité des que l'essentiel est en jeu
est au dessus de tout soupçon
donc vous trouvez que l'opinion
américaine en ce moment est injuste avec
la france un peu mais vous savez c'est
un problème un peu passionnel
aujourd'hui et je comprends parfaitement
ses réactions les attentats contre les
américains ont mis l'opinion publique
américaine à juste titre hors de ses
sens si les commandes pas la cie se
produisait à notre détriment
la france ce qui s'est produit au
détriment des états unis c'est à dire
s'il y avait un attentat qui faisait des
morts parmi des citoyens français et
qu'on puisse vraiment attribué à un état
étranger la limite ou un autre parce
qu'elle n'a pas le monopole
malheureusement quel est le genre de
mesure que vous premier ministre de la
france vous recommande riez je vous
demande pas en dévoiler un plan sont
d'aimer le genre de mesures ce sont des
mesures que l'on n'a pas l'habitude de
dévoiler publiquement mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que les chefs
d'état concernés savent qu'elles
seraient est de la plus grande fermeté
et non seulement si nous-mêmes étions
concernés
et si nos proches alliés l'était
également alors typiquement il ya vous
en disiez un mot tout à l'heure lequel
la tunisie la tunisie à plusieurs
reprises a été menacée d'action
extérieure elle a toujours et encore il
ya que dans l'ajout retrouver la france
à ses côtés sans faiblesse et elle le
sait fort bien alors les européens cette
fois ci se sont concertés à plusieurs
reprises ces jours ci justement à propos
de la lutte contre le terrorisme alors
les ministres affaires étrangères
européens ont pris des décisions qui
sont limitation du nombre et du
déplacement des diplomates libyens en
poste en europe occidentale et puis plus
d'attention de vigilance peut-être de
restriction pour accorder des visas aux
nationaux libyens
est ce que par rapport aux actions du
clan kadhafi ça fait pas un petit peu la
diplomatie de la tasse de thé en face de
celle de la grenade du collage tinkoff
j'en suis pas sûr ce que je crois que
les autorités des pays et notamment la
libye
mais je le répète il n'ya pas que lui
c'est ce que j'ai dit dès 1 qui
encourage le terrorisme doivent être mis
dans une situation d'avoir peur de
prendre ces initiatives et l'ensemble
des mesures connues ou des mesures qui
ont été prises par le canal de la
diplomatie
et de nature je crois à atteindre cet
objectif
en tous les cas chacun doit savoir que
les réactions de la france seront très
ferme dans ce domaine il ne faut pas non
plus sous-estimer les conséquences que
peuvent avoir des actions dont le
résultat est de ressouder une opinion
publique autour d'un gouvernement ou
d'un chef d'état qui par ailleurs
pourrait être contestées là vous pensez
aux raids américains pour dire que 66
ans je penserai d'américains c'est aussi
une face des choses qui doit être
apprécié pensé que ce n'était pas la
bonne rim tiens oui ou bien de rendre de
2,2 de renforcer la solidarité du monde
arabe
même si le sud si celui ci ne tient pas
beaucoup à l'égard de l'un des leurs qui
tout d'un coup est agressée et ceci dans
des conditions alors que l'opinion
publique arabe les deux aujourd'hui
traversé de courants difficile à
maîtriser qui tiennent à la baisse du
niveau de vie qui tiennent au
développement de l'intégrisme qui
tiennent à toutes sortes de choses avec
des gouvernements modérés qui sont les
alliés des etats-unis qui sont nos
alliés et qui peuvent être fragiles si
on laisse se développer ces courants de
contestation et de déstabilisation
là aussi il faut prendre garde de ne pas
trop les alimenter or il faut savoir que
c'est une politique d'ensemble leurs
problèmes de cette ampleur pouvant
comporter les conséquences qu'il peut
comporter doit être au moins apprécié en
commun la concertation que les
américains souhaitent
elle n'a pas été violent cette facilité
que nous et que nous renforcerons à
tokyo je le dis très clairement cette
concertation doit être effective c'est à
dire qu'il faut qu'on puisse en parler
prenons la france elle a également une
expérience arabe
elle a également la capacité de donner
un avis ne peut pas être mise
au pied du mur sans avoir la possibilité
de s'exprimer alors dernière question
sur sur ce sujet quelle impression ce
que ça vous a fait avoue jacques chirac
compte tenu de votre étiquette politique
et de vos convictions politiques dans
cette affaire de vous trouver
apparemment en harmonie avec le
président de la république sinon vous
pouvez tout à fait me démentir ça serait
intéressant et en revanche d'être
critiqué par une fraction non
négligeable de votre majorité en
particulier par valéry giscard d'estaing
par jean-luc annuler président de l'udf
et je passe sur les seigneurs de moindre
importance
vous savez dans une affaire aussi
dramatique que tout ce qui touche au
terrorisme dans une affaire aussi
importante que tout ce qui touche à la
solidarité du monde occidental
il est tout à fait légitime tout à fait
normal que chacun exprime sa sensibilité
et le comprend très bien c'était pas ça
ma question sur le plan de la décision
que j'ai prise
c'est vrai que le président de la
république a eu la même réaction
mais vous savez moi je ne cherche pas à
me définir contre les uns ou les autres
ni même par rapport aux uns ou aux
autres j'essaye de prendre les décisions
en tant que chef du gouvernement qui me
paraissent les meilleurs pour la france
et en intégrant un certain nombre de
données que j'ai de par ma fonction et
qui ne sont pas obligatoirement connu
par tous ceux qui par ailleurs porter le
jugement que je respecte
alors il ya un sujet qui est proche
c'est celui des décisions qui ont été
prises ailleurs en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui même en conseil des
ministres à propos de la lutte en france
cette fois ci contre le terrorisme alors
ayez une question que je me pose est
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas de la part du
gouvernement une sorte de gesticulations
autrement dit il n'ya pas une volonté
d'action psychologique pour changer le
climat et qui en l'occurrence se traduit
peut-être par quelques fois des mesures
qui sont plus symbolique qu'efficace
alors là je pense soit des
interpellations de journalistes parce
qu'évidemment d'excellents journalistes
on en parle beaucoup soit votre ministre
de l'intérieur charles pasqua qui redit
qu'il est pour la peine de mort alors
qu'on sait bien qu'en france pendant
cinq années en tout cas on ne peut pas
revenir là dessus
soit le fait que l'on rétablisse par
exemple
les contrôles d'identité dans les hôtels
alors que votre propre gouvernement
il ya dix ans les avait supprimé est ce
que est ce qu'il n'ya pas la plus sûre
ces trois mesures la plus d'action
psychologique que de réalité des
décisions je crois monsieur lionel que
vous que vous prenez un peu les choses
par le petit bout de la lorgnette
je joue l'avocat du diable c'est la
règle non m par le petit bout de la
lorgnette
mon gouvernement à quelques objectifs et
deux priorités qui ressorte d'ailleurs
clairement de tout ce que l'on a dit
écrit pendant la campagne électorale au
titre de la plate forme commune udf rpr
pour nous la priorité les deux priorités
essentielles c'est d'abord une priorité
d'ordre social
cette priorité nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler jeu s'appelle brune
jeuland a brièvement c'est plus que
l'emploi c'est un encens c'est une
conception d'une politique sociale dont
l'objectif est d'abord et avant tout de
réduire les inégalités et la première
d'entre elles qui est le chemin avec
parallèlement deux impératifs qui
s'impose au même titre et qui
s'interpénètrent qui la lutte contre
l'inflation laquelle met en cause le
niveau de vie des gens et le maintien de
la protection sociale
cet ensemble nous en reparlerons tout à
l'heure je descends
cet ensemble est une priorité absolue la
deuxième priorité qui consiste aussi à
réduire une inégalité qui s'est
développée dans
au cours des derniers temps ne se dote
pas seulement 1980 c'est celle qui
touche à cette liberté essentielle la
première de tout et qui tiens ta à la
sécurité des personnes et des biens
plus on me dit que je n'excuse
sécuritaire etc tout ça m'indiffère
totalement ce que je sais c'est que le
développement de la délinquance de la
drogue de la criminalité touche qui en
premier
toujours les plus vulnérables les plus
faibles ceux qui habitent dans les
quartiers les moins aisés et c est qu on
a développé là comme avec le chômage au
nom de je ne sais quel idéalisme en
vertu de jugement d'esprit faut bien
loin des préoccupations populaires
on a développé la une inégalité qui fait
que dans certains quartiers des gens
sont plus que notre agressé des jeunes
filles n'osent pas sortir
par conséquent il faut lutter contre
cela et le gouvernement à engager une
politique qui est une deuxième priorité
alors s'il te permettre de prendre tout
un ensemble de dispositions que le
ministre de l'intérieur a développé ce
matin ainsi d'ailleurs que le ministre
de la justice car tout cela est
naturellement interpénétrés il va de soi
qu'il ne saurait être question pour nous
monsieur duhamel de prendre quelques
mesures que ce soit qui ne seraient pas
conformes aux droits de l'homme au
respect qu'on leur doit
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce matin le
président de la république est intervenu
pour dire qu'il fallait justement
veillée quand on prend ce genre de
mesure à ce que la liberté soit pas mise
en cause les droits de l'individu soit
respectée n'attendez pas de moi que je
vous fasse un commentaire public du
conseil des ministres conseillers pas
une information à tous les cas je vais
vous dire une chose et monsieur duhamel
s'il l'avait fait il aurait eu raison
mais de toute façon si tant est inutile
car il va de soi que mon gouvernement
n'a pas un instant l'intention de faire
quoique ce soit qui pourrait être
contraire à aux droits de l'homme et
d'ailleurs nous avons nommé pour être
bien sûr d'avoir un conseiller compétent
efficace ans résidant partout un
secrétaire d'état aux droits de l'homme
la personne de monsieur l'alluré et je
lui ai demandé d'être très vigilants et
si j'ose dire de tirer la sonnette
chaque fois qu'ils lui apparaîtrait que
quelque chose de dangereux peut être par
inadvertance des faits alors justement à
propos la sécurité puisque vous dites
vous même que c'est une des deux
priorités du gouvernement
cette affaire d'utiliser un certain
nombre d'appelés volontaire du
contingent à des tâches de maintien de
l'ordre
en quoi est-ce que ça consisterait
concrètement nous avons déjà des appelés
vous le savez dans l'armée la liste dans
la gendarmerie
au début quand cela a été décidé
certains critiquaient maintenant tout le
monde est très satisfait on a énormément
de deux candidats pourquoi ne pas le
faire également dans la police ce sont
des volontaires
mais là encore monsieur duhamel c'est
pas le problème je veux dire vous prenez
petite-pierre pas petit ps et de
percevoir le mur qui est construit à
partir de ces pièces sont les mesures
nouvelles
oui mais il y en a un très grand nombre
nous allons avoir en réalité une
politique qui en matière de sécurité a
consisté d'abord à nous donner davantage
de moyens techniques et matériels et
financiers des financiers par voie de
conséquence face au yen en vie cathy
façon significative et il met déjà dans
le collectif que nous venons de
s'arrêter et de présenter à l'assemblée
nationale et ensuite dans le budget de
toute une série de mesures qui va
renforcer les moyens de la police
deuxièmement nous allons utiliser la
police de façon je l'espère plus
efficace et en lui ayant rendu confiance
parce qu'elle sent aujourd'hui que la
considération qu'on doit lui porter
compte tenu de la nature de sa mission
et indiscuté et que nous ferons en sorte
qu'elle soit respectée et enfin qu'alain
duhamel et enfin et enfin nous allons
nous doter des moyens juridiques qui
nous font défaut actuellement
pour nous permettre de lutter
efficacement contre à la fois la
criminalité la délinquance et le
développement de la drogue et bien
entendu
alors virieu me faisais seuil et vous
pouvez être sûr que la situation
s'améliorera très sensiblement ça j'en
prends l'engagement dans les endroits
pendant un engagement comme ça eh bien
vous savez je suis plutôt réaliste et je
me méfie beaucoup des engagements je
suis donc en général très prudent
pendant toute la campagne
j'ai refusé d'entendre dans les
différents domaines on me dit c'est vous
même ou bien vous avez créé d'emplois
combien je n'ai pris aucun bleu alors
laquelle votre en six ans qu'il y aura
une amélioration sensible de la sécurité
et en particulier pour je dirais tous
les français toutes les françaises et
des français qui sont je le répète les
plus faibles et les plus vulnérables n 1
en ut efficacement contre cette
inégalité sociale qu'a créé le
développement de la sécu il faut en même
temps pour ça pour qui les résultats
s'il y aurait des résultats positifs
j'en suis persuadé dès le début de
l'année proche
bon alors ma dernière question le même
jour une dernière question
au passage on aura quelques jours aussi
pour jourdain la question pour
aujourd'hui quand vous aviez démissionné
de vos fonctions en 1976 vous aviez dit
que vous ne disposiez plus d'assez de
pouvoir pour une serre c'est votre
autorité moyens oui ce portrait
différent
bon disons de moyens disons de moyens
alors est ce que vous considérez que
vous avez aujourd'hui davantage de
moyens avec françois mitterrand à
l'elysée qu' avec valéry giscard
d'estaing à l'elysée et avec trois voix
de majorité à l'assemblée nationale
qu'avec une cinquantaine de voix de
majorité
alain somme initiale comme c'était le
cas à ce moment-là peut-être vous
étonner mais oui sans aucun doute à cet
intéressant ça oui ce n'est pas à vous
monsieur duhamel que je rappellerai que
la constitution comporte un article 20
que cet article 20 précise que le
gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation de la nation bien
et j'ai l'intention avec mon
gouvernement de déterminer et de
conduire la politique de la nation
et vous en des gens et assyriens et j'en
ai dix ans j'en ai la totalité des
moyens
j'en assume la totalité de la
responsabilité avec une équipe qui est
une équipe unie une équipe solidaire et
une équipe déterminée et vous avez plus
de moyens qu'à dix ans sans aucun doute
puisque le système est aujourd'hui
différent et je l'espère d'ailleurs
provisoire merci merci alain duhamel
alors pendant que pendant lequel un
duhamel poursuivez-vous son dialogue
impossible à interrompre on a interrogé
la sofres interrogé son échantillon sur
cette question comme très intéressante
du degré de solidarité avec les états
unis très intéressante parce qu'elle fit
sûr quand même un petit peu votre votre
majorité et alors pour la question était
il semble que votre il semble que votre
attitude est en tout cas l'explication
vous avez donné de votre attitude est
convaincu par ce que je vois que 55% des
gens approuvent l'attitude que vous avez
prises
et 34% seulement pensent qu'il aurait
fallu être plus solidaires dans les
manifestations dans les démonstrations
des américains la question était contre
le terrorisme la france doit-elle avoir
envers les états unis l'attitude plus
solidaire d'hôtel avoir la même attitude
sans opinion d'ailleurs il ya peu de
sans opinion
11% je me suis même à terme c'est dire
oui très bref je n'aime pas le mot
solidaire il n'a pas de signification
nous sommes totalement solidaires de
l'ensemble de nos alliés notamment dans
un face à un problème comme celui du
terrorisme nous sommes totalement
solidaires à 100% ce n'est pas faillir à
la solidarité que de porter un jugement
sur une initiative dont nous n'étions
pas préalablement informés et dont une
commission par les objectifs et qui
risquait de nous entraîner sur une voie
que nous estimions dangereuse ça
méritait au moins que l'on puisse en
parler
donc c'est pas notre solidarité qui est
en cause c'est notre appréciation d'une
action déterminée c'est tout à fait
différent
les américains pensent prennent le mot
trouve que nous avons manqué de
solidarité
est il exact qu'on est con et 10 par
exemple qu'on n'accepterait pas sur la
base de solenzara les amis on les avions
américains en détresse éventuels ont
coutume chez leur retour je suis j'ai
j'ai vu qu'un journal avait publié avait
écrit cette information je suis
scandalisé scandalisé cette information
est monstrueuse jamais jamais aucun état
civilisé et notamment la france ne peut
imaginer de refuser à n'importe quel
avion que ce soit un atterrissage en cas
de difficultés on n'a jamais vu ça et le
fait d'imaginer que la france aurait pu
prendre cette attitude monstrueuse est
absolument scandaleuse je suis indigné
je tiens à le dire très clairement
d'accord et pas seulement pour des
avions gris cas pour n'importe quel
avion bien longtemps d'accord alors nous
retournons asvp jean-louis de seine oui
monsieur le premier ministre on vous
demande de vous justifier dans
bien des domaines de la vie économique
et sociale pouvez-vous justifier la
suppression de l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes l'anonymat sur l'or et
l'amnistié fiscale sur les rentrées de
capitaux de l'étranger alors qu'un
modeste citoyen ne peut lui soustraire
un centime de sa déclaration d'impôt
dans une question qui vous surprend
porte non pas du tout je voudrais
répondre mais j'aurai l'occasion de le
faire tout à l'air plus longue marche
j'en suis sûr avec les journalistes kim
intervieweront nous n'avons qu'une seule
préoccupation est qu'un seul objectif
c'est la réduction du chômage réduire le
chômage ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
créer des emplois créer des emplois
c'est tout
c'est dans les entreprises et créer des
emplois dans les entreprises ça veut
dire qu'il faut les inciter à le faire
je ne développerai tout à l'heure pour
inciter les entreprises à le faire il
faut qu'il y ait un minimum d'intérêt
parmi l'ensemble des mesures que nous
avons prises on vient d'en distraire 3
qu'il est facile d'exploiter à partir du
moment où on les extraits d'une
politique d'ensemble mais qui s'intègre
en réalité dans une politique qui tente
à faire en sorte que les entreprises
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
créer le maximum d'emplois pour que l'on
puisse réduire cette inégalité est
essentielle qu'est celle du chômage
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir tout à
l'heure alors gardez vous de de juger je
demande aux français de bien comprendre
qu'il ne s'agit pas pour nous de faire
des cadeaux ou je ne sais quelle
politique de classe comme on disait il y
a quelques mois mais simplement d'avoir
une politique sociale cohérente qui
répondent aux vrais besoins du pays
les besoins du pays aujourd'hui c'est de
créer des emplois notamment pour les
jeunes
oui mais est-ce que justement si ces
questions sont posées parce que ce n'est
pas un petit peu que les gens on manque
d'explications moment je vais trier
c'est préserver une région c'est donc on
retourne décès soit je me réjouis
médication et c'est pourquoi je me
réjouis d'avoir la possibilité de le
dire si nous faisons rentrer des
capitaux ce n'est pas pour féliciter
ceux qui les ont sortis c'est parce que
nous sommes réalistes et que nous avons
besoin de capitaux car ce parce que ses
capitaux vont
s'investir et que s'investissant ils
vont créer de l'activité de la richesse
et surtout de l'emploi
si nous avons si nous sommes revenus sur
l'anonymat sur l'ours et pour la même
raison
j'ajoute que tous les français sont
favorables les sondages de 10 à
l'anonymat sur l'or parce qu'ils ont
tous une petite bourse avec quelques
lingots d'or notamment nos paysans qui
sont très favorables moi je me suis fait
pour attraper dans ma circonscription
par les paysans quand on a supprimé la
nomination lors je leur ai dit que j
étais pour rien mais mon quelques tout
de même n'est pas raisonnable
il demande d'ailleurs d'aller plus loin
il ya très longtemps qu'on l'a remis
dans les masters les dispositions
réglementaires qui vont appliquer la
bonne image option avait d'ailleurs que
certains chauffeurs de taxi que j'ai
rencontrés avec même la même réaction
il en va de même pour les mesures de
l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes
nous allons dans le même esprit et pour
un montant équivalent relevé le la barre
en dessous de laquelle on ne paie plus
d'impôt sur le revenu
c'est à dire que nous allons faire un
geste significatives en matière en
matière d'amélioration du revenu des
plus défavorisés et ce qui représente à
peu près les choses n'avaient pas les
lèvres mais pourtant nous l'avons
annoncé
bien sûr tout cela prend effet à compter
du 1er janvier 87 et non pas aujourd'hui
et les mesures d'allégement des impôts
pour les plus défavorisés
toute une tranche importante de gens qui
aujourd'hui payent l'impôt sur le revenu
et qu'ils ne paieront plus parce que
leurs revenus sont trop faibles
à nos yeux pour qu'ils soient taxés
c'est un moyen de soutenir les revenus
des plus défavorisés mais l'impôt sur
les grandes fortunes était un impôt
profondément injuste ceux qui avaient
des meubles des des tableaux et cetera
ne paient rien et ceux qui avaient une
entreprise était obligé de payer souvent
au détriment des investissements de leur
entreprise et par conséquent de l'emploi
l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes à
stériliser la construction et résultat
vous voyez ce qui se passe le nombre de
gens qui aujourd'hui cherchent des ans
des logements et n'en trouve pas on a
stérilisé la construction alors il faut
être faut pas seulement résonnèrent
matière d'idéal il faut être un peu
réaliste et se dire qu'une société
c'est un ensemble qui doit fonctionner
pour la satisfaction du plus grand
nombre de ces enfants bien alors
philippe alexandre pour un quart d'heure
l'ips alexandre de rtl
je pensais que vous seriez plus fatigué
parce que depuis un mois vous êtes
transformer en tornade sur ce pays alors
là vous posez la question c'est fatigués
non justement je pensais que vous seriez
plus fatigués alors pourquoi cette
précipitation est ce que vous avez peur
de manquer de temps et pourquoi si peu
de débat parlementaire est ce que vous
avez peur de manquer de voix pourquoi
vite
d'abord
pour deux raisons la première je le
répète nous avons aujourd'hui en france
entre un jeune sur trois et un jeune sur
quatre de moins de 25 ans qui sont au
chômage
il n'y a pas une société qui peut
accepter une telle inégalité sociale
profond tout le reste est secondaire par
rapport à cette injustice et il n'y a
pas lieu de perdre de temps pour engager
une politique tendant à remédier à cette
situation a créé les emplois
nous en parlerons probablement voilà
pourquoi nous sommes pressés la deuxième
raison c'est que cette politique
permettant de créer des emplois exigent
la confiance la confiance internationale
et la confiance de ceux qui petit moyen
ou grand ont la possibilité de créer les
emplois parce qu'ils ont la possibilité
d'investir dans leur entreprise
cette confiance doit s'acquérir
rapidement si nous donnons l'impression
que nous laissons aller les choses alors
les gens se diront bombe
tout ça c'était des mots ça ne vient pas
nous avons immédiatement fait un
réajustement monétaire je voudrais vous
dire quelque chose car j'ai entendu
certain nombre de propos d'observateurs
politiques depuis 1945
il y a eu beaucoup de réajustement
monétaire malheureusement de dévaluation
pour appeler les choses par leur nom
il n'y en a eu aucune je dis bien aucune
même s'il n'est pas d'usagé de citer de
chiffres qui étaient étaient aussi
extraordinairement positive que celle
que nous avons fait il ya trois semaines
au niveau de la rentrée massive de
capitaux et de devises en france ce qui
nous permettra d'ailleurs est ce qui
nous permet d'engager une politique de
diminution des taux d'intérêt ce qui
sera favorable à tout le monde et
notamment à ceux qui veulent investir et
l'autre par de rembourser avant terme
une dette extérieure qui avaient atteint
des proportions à l'évidence trop grande
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous avons créé la confiance
internationale
mais la confiance internationale ça
c'est précaire par nature ça peut ne pas
durer il faut donc que par une action
très rapide sur le plan intérieur
dans le domaine économique et dans le
domaine social car pour nous l'objectif
est un objectif social l'économique
n'est que le moyen de faire une
politique sociale il faut que nous
allions vite
soit vous dites peu de débat mais
philippe lexandre il y a eu six mois de
campagne pendant lesquelles ce débat a
été développée non pas seulement dans le
parlement mais dans toute la nation
pendant des milliers et des milliers
d'heures non pas les ordonnances plus
l'article 49-3 je veux dire que vraiment
le le système parlementaire est réduit à
la portion congrue
non non
les les lois d'habilitation que nous
avons demandé la loi d'habilitation
économique et sociale que nous avons
d'augmenter est une loi qui est limité
aux problèmes économiques
car j'ai toujours dit que les problèmes
sociaux je les dis le jour où j'ai été
nommé premier ministre je l'avais dit
pendant la campagne qui avait fait
l'objet de grands débats devaient être
traités au parlement ils le seront mais
il y avait là urgence sur les problèmes
économiques
c'est ce que nous avons fait et je le
répète il s'agit de sujets qui ne mérite
pas plus d'une semaine de débats au
parlement
ou alors c'est de l'obstruction
parlementaire c'est un autre problème
politique celui ci vous me permettrez de
vous dire qu'après tout ce qui a été dit
depuis six mois tout ce qui a permis
d'informer depuis six mois l'opinion
publique nous permet maintenant d'aller
rapidement avec je le répète c'est
unique objectif qui est le nôtre et qui
consiste à créer des emplois
alors si j'en crois tout ce que je lis
et j'écoute cette maison nous sommes
antenne 2 va être très bientôt
privatisée et même du thon vendu au
groupe hachette
alors c'est en effet une espèce de une
espèce de logique du libéralisme qui
veut que en matière de communication
audiovisuelle en effet ofas succéder à
une monarchie étatique si je puis dire
une oligarchie financière alors quelles
garanties
pouvez vous donner aux français pour que
les choses se passent dans le pluralisme
dans la démocratie et qu'on ne voit pas
des groupes financiers se jeter sur ce
territoire audiovisuelle avec une
avidité un peu suspecte séjour dire
d'abord que c'est pas le premier
problème qui préoccupe les français
deuxièmement le ministre de la culture
et de la communication monsieur léotard
est en train d'étudier avec toute la
concertation nécessaire ce que doit être
ce que doivent être les mesures à
prendre en matière de communication et
il lui appartiendra de faire ses
propositions d'ailleurs
très prochaine au gouvernement
troisièmement nous avons le gouvernement
est bien décidé à ce qu'il n'y ait
aucune ambiguïté sur la transparence
ça veut dire que nous aurons une
nouvelle haute autorité qu'on appellera
la commission nationale de la
communication et sera différente de la
haute autorité que je ne critique pas le
choix je n'ai jamais critiqué l'action
de la haute autorité
je vais me reconnu l'aspect positif de
son action mais qui aura il sera plus
d'indépendance beaucoup plus
d'indépendance grâce notamment à la
présence de magistrats incontesté et qui
aura plus de pouls et à partir de là
chacun assumera ses responsabilités dans
un système qui doit être effectivement
aussi privatiser que possible ce qui
n'exclut pas le maintien cela va de soi
d'un secteur public et qui à mes yeux
doit être d'autant plus important qu'il
sera un secteur de référence mais le
justement quand on voit ce que fait la
télévision privée actuellement on se dit
après tout que la télé ville le service
public la voix de la france comme disait
georges pompidou n'a pas fait du si
mauvais travail
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous réduisez
la voix de la france et le service
public à une portion très très étroite
et que vous donnez la part si belle au
secteur privé tout simplement parce que
ce n'est pas dans la vocation de l'état
de gérer l'essentiel de la communication
audiovisuelle c'est pas dans sa vocation
quand il le fait il risque de le faire
avec des tentations d'ingérence quel
qu'il soit c'est fatal il vaut mieux que
les chaînes soit aussi indépendante que
possible et donc privée et puis il le
fait dans des conditions économiques
je n'ai pas besoin d'insister qui hélas
enfin économique ça veut dire financière
qui hélas ne sont pas très très très
bonne alors il y a un intérêt sans aucun
doute avoir un secteur privatisées mais
qui n'exclut pas je le répète un secteur
public de référence et qui restera
naturellement
mais alors deux chaînes le ministre
compétent et dieu sait qu'il l'est
notamment dans ce domaine fera des
propositions au gouvernement qui ont
délibérera et qui décidera
ne confondons pas apte ce qui est notre
ambition et précipitation ce que nous
voulons éviter comme dit mon ami mon ami
guy drut une est à la fois mais mais
justement vous avez précisé à
l'assemblée nationale que vous alliez
publié rende public est très clairement
la liste des entreprises qui seraient
privatisées
est-ce que vous donnerez également un
calendrier très précis année par année
des privatisations qui se forment
impossible impossible tout dépend des
disponibilités du marché financier de
tout dépend de la situation financière
des entreprises si elles sont en
excédent ou un déficit donc il faut
faire les choses de façon très
pragmatique nous engagerons une
processus qui en quelques années mais je
me garderai d'en définir le nombre nous
permettra de rendre au secteur privé
tout ce qui appartient au secteur
concurrentiel et qui est aujourd'hui
entre les mains de l'état l'état doit
être le garant d'un certain nombre
d'assurances sur le plan social comme
sur le plan économique il ne doit être
le gérant des affaires ce n'est pas son
rôle
alors j'entends dans la majorité des
voix d'ailleurs de plus en plus
nombreuses et de plus en plus bruyante
s'indigner que les têtes n'est pas
changé à la télévision comme si au fond
les français est appelé à choisir des
députés et en même temps à choisir les
les
journalistes de l'audiovisuel quand ils
votent alors est-ce que vous résisterez
à cette espèce de chasse aux sorcières
dont l'expression qui est déclenchée
dans votre propre majorité
je trouve ça un peu osé de parler de
chasse aux sorcières n'est ce pas vous
pouvez vous citer un cas j'en prend des
rebonds 10 passes
philippe alexandre parler d'apple via un
appel est ce que vous allez résister à
ces mouvements je vous dis de la façon
la plus claire que je n'ai pas du tout
pour ce qui me concerne et je crois
savoir que c'est tout à fait le
sentiment du ministre de la culture et
de la communication et de tous les
membres du gouvernement il en être un
certain nombre ici n'ont pas l'intention
de faire la moindre chasse à la sorcière
et si nous voulons précisément avoir une
commission nationale dès qu'ils soient
totalement indépendants et qu'ils soient
très puissant et si nous voulons
privatiser un certain nombre chaîne
c'est précisément pour que chacun assume
ses responsabilités et que l'état n'est
pas à porter de jugement et a fortiori à
prendre de décision en ce qui concerne
les journalistes ça c'est tout à fait
clair mais alors précisément on voir
dans la perspective de cette
privatisation une façon générale se
constituer des groupes de réserves
financières même se créer des sociétés
quelles garanties pouvez vous donner aux
français que les choses se passeront
autrement pour le cinquième jeune vôtre
vous le garantis ce sera jugée par la
commission nationale de la communication
et croyez moi c'est pas le sujet qui
préoccupe le plus les français
monsieur chirac la jda tout à l'heure je
parle de la privatisation en général
quelles garanties pourront nous à voir
que les choses se passeront sans
spéculation sent prête noms sans
intervention de capitaux étrangers
bref que les choses se passeront sans
sans copinage et coco et coquinerie vous
en aurez toutes les garanties
nécessaires elles sont d'ailleurs prévus
dans les dispositions à la fois 2
des principes de la loi d'habilitation
dans les modalités de mise en oeuvre qui
seront prévues par les ordonnances et
personne ne pourra je vous rassure tout
de suite mettre en cause la transparence
totale total de cette affaire ça c'est
un engagement que je peux prendre
monsieur de virieu ce soir de la façon
la plus formelle personne ne pourra
critiquer les modalités de la
privatisation des entreprises en général
ni la volonté de l'état de défendre
âprement ce qui est son intérêt ou ses
intérêts dans les entreprises qui sont
actuellement sa propriété et qu'il
vendre il y aura une commission qui sera
chargée d'orienter les moyens
nécessaires seront mis en oeuvre et
personne ne pourra critique vous ne
pouvez pas lire le garant tu ne pouvais
pas dire quels moyens
non parce qu'ils sont prévues dans
lordonnance en développement soient
sortis pendant la campagne électorale
vous aviez beaucoup dit que dès que vous
arriveriez au goût certain puisque
c'était bill peut-être que vous
envisagiez le plus volontiers il serait
fait une espèce de bilan un état des
lieux en quelque sorte
et depuis un mois on n'a pas vu ce
travail entrepris alors on a parlé aussi
d'un rapport de monsieur de la gêne yen
on n'a pas vu sa publication
alors je vais vous demander au fond
est-ce que vous pourquoi ce retard est
ce que vous craignez que ce travail ne
soient pas aussi sévères à l'encontre de
la précédente gestion que vous pensiez
ou alors au contraire est-ce qu'il faut
inscrire sa dans le cadre de la
cohabitation et du désir de ne pas
envenimer les bons rapports que vous
entretenez avec le président de la
république je veux dire la vérité figure
d'exemple c'est ni l'une ni l'autre de
ces deux raisons et pourtant vous avez
juste titre souligné que nous avons un
peu de retard dans la publication de ce
bilan est la raison c'est simplement que
nous nous sommes d'abord consacré avec
que toutes nos forces et toutes nos
énergies et dans tous les ministères a
engagé une politique de redressement
conforme aux engagements que nous avions
pris 2 pendant la campagne m
et peut-être et ça j'en assume la
responsabilité je comprends la critique
n'avons nous pas était suffisamment vite
sur le plan du bilan ont poussé en même
temps c'était pas vrai on peut faire les
gendarmes ont naturellement on doit
faire les deux en même temps mais je
veux dire que nous avons mis toute notre
énergie à mettre en place les nouveaux
textes je voudrais avant de finir de
répondre sur ce bilan vous donner une
petite idée de ce qui peut être fait en
un mois nous avons dû faire un
réajustement monétaire nous avons fait
un collectif budgétaire le budget dont
nous avons hérité était un budget qui
n'étaient pas réalistes tout le monde le
savait il a fallu faire un collectif
budgétaire notamment pour augmenter un
certain nombre de crédits à vocation
sociale pour des mesures décidées avant
nous mais qui n'avait pas été financés
ou très insuffisamment il a fallu
parallèlement engagé une politique de
diminution des déficits donc faire 10
milliards d'économies sur ce collectif
exercice sans précédent tout ceci ne se
fait pas tout seul nous avons décidé
après concertation naturellement avec
les organisations syndicales le maintien
du pouvoir d'achat mais pas
d'augmentation dans le service public
dans le secteur public avec les
conséquences que cela comporte sur le
secteur privé donc la nécessité d'une
solidarité nationale à l'égard de la
priorité qui est la création d'emplois
et la réduction de cette inégalité
nous avons baissé les taux d'intérêts
nous avons engagé une nouvelle politique
monétaire beaucoup plus rigoureuse pour
lutter efficacement contre l'inflation
je parlais de l'emploi et de l'inflation
l'inflation
lorsqu'elle se développe
à quoi pour conséquence que nos
industries deviennent moins compétitifs
puisque nos produits sont plus chers que
ceux par exemple des allemands or nous
sommes un pays où près d'un travailleur
sur trois travaillent pour l'exportation
donc si nous exportons moins
naturellement le chômage se développe
donc politique de lutte contre
l'inflation est aussi importante pour
nous d'où une politique monétaire plus
rigoureuse
nous avons décidé la libérer la liberté
des changes pratiquement total la
liberté des prix pratiquement total nous
avons supprimé les seuils fiscaux nous
avons effectivement pris un certain
nombre de mesures de confiance dont
certaines ont été rappelés tout à
l'heure nous avons pris des mesures en
faveur du revenu des agriculteurs
notamment en matière fiscale et pour le
fuel
nous avons fait un plan d'emploi des
jeunes ça n'a pas été facile car c'est
un plan de grande ampleur et qui
consiste non pas à faire recruter des
jeunes dans les services administratifs
à mi temps et je ne sais comment mais à
les insérer dont l'entreprise donc à
inciter l'entreprise à créer des emplois
de jeunes c'était une grande affaire
nous avons tant de faire l'état des
lieux
nous avons engagé une réforme du droit
de la concurrence qui a besoin d'être
modernisée notamment notamment en faveur
de l'ensemble du secteur des petites et
moyennes entreprises je pense tout
particulièrement un secteur qui a
souffert et dont nous attendons beaucoup
sur le plan de la solidarité en matière
de prix comme en matière d'emploi et qui
est l'artisanat et le commerce
nous avons fait engager la mise au point
d'une charte des contribuables pour que
ceci ne soit plus systématiquement eux
soupçonnés du pire n'est ce pas sans
qu'il ne puisse sans qu'on apporte la
preuve de ses soupçons
nous avons engagé la réforme de la loi
électorale
nous avons mis en chantier toute une
série de projets de loi qui concerne la
suppression de l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement pour que
les effectifs puissent être gérés dans
des conditions permettant à l'emploi de
secret nous avons
bien chantier une loi pour supprimer les
effets de seuil qui paralyse une loi
pour relancer l'activité dans les
départements et les territoires
d'outre-mer
une autre très importante pour
l'investissement immobilier et le
développement de l'accession sociale à
la propriété et pour répondre aux
exigences du secteur sinistré s'il en
est qui est celui du bâtiment et des
travaux publics
la loi sur la communication dont je
parlais tout à l'heure les mesures en
matière de sécurité
conques et de et de lutte contre le
terrorisme et la sécurité
la loi sur l'éducation nous avons mis en
oeuvre la loi d'orientation agricole
j'ai engagé une loi de programmation
militaire une loi sur l'autonomie de la
banque de france
bref vous voyez l'ampleur des mesures
qui je vous ai demandé de venir le
premier mois parce que si on a moins une
heure c'est vraiment ça veut dire que
nous avons un gouvernement qui travaille
alors je reconnu que dans tout cela
non parce que vous de la préoccupation
en matière de bilan a été un peu laissé
de côté donc il faut maintenant
rattraper ce retard d'urgence nous le
faisons d'une part sur le plan du
gouvernement et vous aurez notamment les
premiers résultats dans les prochains
jours
et d'autre part nous sommes entendus
avec le parlement et avec la commission
des finances pour que celle ci soit
chargé par son président de
l'élaboration d'un bilan après tout la
commission des finances est à dire une
instance parlementaire doté de tous les
pouvoirs d'investigation de recherche a
probablement une une vocation et et une
crédibilité plus grande pour faire
également un état des lieux et un bilan
enfin j'ai demandé à chaque ministre
sous l'autorité d'une personnalité aussi
incontestable que possible de faire
faire le bilan de son propre ministère
des actions passées bon
une petite question time to go terrien
toute petite dernière question le
président de la république a indiqué que
certaines certaines ordonnances ne
serait pas signé par lui on peut obliger
personne à signer cantina parents dit
qu'est ce que vous ferez dans cette
hypothèse est ce que vous démissionnez
est-ce que vous traînez le président de
la république en haute cour ou est-ce
que vous solliciter l'arbitrage du
conseil constitutionnel vous ne
l'imaginez pas dupe lexandre que je vais
prendre ensemble de téléspectateurs à
témoin de telle ou telle difficulté avec
le président de la république il y a je
le répète une constitution une volonté
de l'appliquer
le premier qui dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition je prendrai l'initiative de
déroger à cette règle en assumerait
toute la responsabilité personne ne le
fera
le jeu ne craint donc rien et le moment
venu puisque le problème ne s'est pas
présenté je le règle récoltes soins
merci vibrer xandre alors on va revenir
un tout petit peu en arrière parce que
tout à l'heure
alain duhamel vous demander si vous
aviez les moyens de
que vous n'aviez pas en 76 il ya dix ans
alors on a posé la question à la sofres
a posé la question à son échantillon
avez vous le sentiment que le
gouvernement de monsieur chirac a les
moyens voyant n'a repris votre mot a les
moyens de déterminer de conduire la
politique de la nation
et bien apparemment
les gens interrogés sont satisfaits des
explications 62% estiment que oui 22%
estiment que non les opinions 16 un
commentaire ce qui prouve que les
français connaissent mieux la
constitution qu'on ne le dit
généralement svp jean-louis de seine oui
monsieur premier bilan revient à
l'économie aux mesures que vous
préconisez de les questions ici sont les
plus nombreux ce soir svt sur le domaine
économique pourquoi avoir touché c'est
un exemple pourquoi avoir touché au taux
du livret a
ce qui pénalise beaucoup les petits
épargnants c'est vrai que tout à l'heure
vous avez dit la baisse des taux
d'intérêts c'est bon pour tout le monde
alors évidemment je sentais bien que les
épargnants à les poser des questions là
oui mais ce qui est bon par les ânes
mais pas pour les autres on ne sait pas
qui a posé la question je voudrais
rappeler que nous n'avons pas toucher au
taux du livret a certains ont évoqué
l'idée que l'on pourrait avec la baisse
des taux et je dois dire tout à fait
naturellement et baissé aussi les taux
du livret a mais cette décision n'a pas
encore été 2e lie un problème de vases
communicants qui m'échappe un peu
comment est-ce qu'on peut prêter moins
cher l'argent tout en empruntant au
moment où métaux à partir du moment où
les taux d'intérêt baissent ils baissent
naturellement pour tout le monde et
partout et livré à connaissent
aujourd'hui un taux d intérêts
particulièrement élevé et je m'en
réjouis parce que ça ce sont c'est une
épargne je dirais modeste populaire est
nécessaire
enfin il va de soi que quand tous les
taux baissent les taux des livrets a et
b seront aussi enfin je rassure tout de
suite le
celui qui a posé la question nous
n'avons pas toucher aux taux des livrets
autre question jean louis la scène oui
monsieur chirac vous prenez beaucoup de
mesures pour les jeunes au chômage c'est
parfait 10 et téléspectateurs mais les
plus de 40 ans avec des charges
familiales que faites-vous pour eux
d'abord dans le plan qui a été arrêté
par le gouvernement et dont les crédits
figure au collectif ce qui devrions nous
a obligés à faire des réductions
importantes de dépenses de l'état chacun
ne se passera obligés de faire des
sacrifices il y à des sommes non
négligeables qui intéresse précisément
les gens qui sont dans la situation que
vous venez de rappeler le chômage même
si celui des jeunes est particulièrement
angoissant pour la stabilité de notre
société
le chômage n'est pas plus cruel pour les
uns et pour les autres et le père de
famille
de 45 ans de 50 ans qui se trouve tout
d'un coup avec ses charges et sans
travail est dans une situation dont le
caractère dramatique n'échappe à
personne et qui d'ailleurs explique le
développement de cette nouvelle pauvreté
qui est la saga aguerris zélés les deux
dernières années donc une politique
d'emploi est une politique d'ensemble et
je le répète toutes les mesures que nous
prenons toutes sans exception même si a
priori elles apparaissent éloigné n'ont
qu'un objectif c'est de s'intégrer dans
un ensemble cohérent tendant à permettre
aux entreprises de créer des emplois et
elles ne créeront pas par définition que
des emplois pour les jeunes
même si elles s'y sont incités par des
mesures particulières il faut qu'elles
développent leurs activités pour cela
qu'elle y soit incitée qu'elles aient
confiance
quel est le sentiment que si elles se
développent et qu'elles ont des
difficultés demain elles ne seront pas
pour autant sanctionnés alors ça évitera
bien des licenciements alors ça
permettra de recruter à nouveau et pas
seulement des jeunes car il est des
postes qui doivent être recrutés parmi
des hommes ou des femmes d'expérience
parce que nous voulons réalité c'est que
chaque entreprise de bain et notamment
dans les petites et moyennes entreprises
se disent eh bien oui
maintenant on peut y aller on y est un
site et on a les moyens nous n'allons
pas être sanctionnés le cas échéant nous
allons être libérée d'un certain nombre
des contraintes qui pour le moment nous
paralyse on nous fait confiance faisons
à notre tour confiance et je fais un
appel solennel à tous ces chefs
d'entreprise notamment des petites et
moyennes entreprises artisanales
commerciales industrielles libéral qui
ont deux trois cinq salariés avantages
aussi bien sûr je fais un appel à eux
pour leur dire vous pouvez avoir
confiance
vous ne serez pas déçus ni sanctionné ce
que nous voulons c'est que vous
investissiez votre argent votre
imagination pour créer les emplois dont
on a besoin et je fais un appel à tous
les salariés pour qu'ils comprennent que
notre ambition notre seule ambition
c'est de réduire cette inégalité qui les
frappe plus que toutes les autres
alors il ya ce naturellement qu'ils ont
un emploi et notamment ceux qui ont un
emploi privilégié et je pense notamment
à nos compatriotes fonctionnaires et qui
doivent bien comprendre que le problème
aujourd'hui sur le plan social ce n'est
pas pour chacun de ceux qui ont un
travail d'améliorer leur situation
c'est d'abord et avant tout de faire le
geste global de solidarité qui
permettent de créer les moyens
permettant de donner à ceux qui n'ont
pas d'emploi l'emploi dont ils ont
besoin qu'il soit jeune et c'est ça
toute notre politique et c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé à tous les ministres
même pour des choses qui peuvent
apparaître comme mesquine de réduire
systématiquement leur niveau de vie si
j'ai demandé que les ministres n'utilise
presque plus les avions du glam
ce n'est pas pour les bris mais
naturellement ce n'est pas pour ce que
ça coûte cela va de soi c'est aussi
parce que je considère que chacun
aujourd'hui doit faire un effort
un petit effort pour que tous ensemble
nous puissions avoir la possibilité de
créer ces emplois qui nous manque pour
les jeunes et pour les moins jeunes cela
va de soi pour les hommes et pour les
femmes
si nombreuse au chômage aujourd'hui
c'est pour une histoire a continué avec
albert du roi albert du roy pour un
quart d'heure 21h36
bonjour monsieur du roi l'appel que vous
avez fait au ministre pour qu'il fasse
des économies notamment qu'il le prenne
le moins possible les avions du
groupement de liaisons aériennes
interministériel est ce que est ce qu a
votre avis il serait normal lui sera
normal que le président de la république
prenne le concorde ball à tokyo
président de la république que donne une
certaine image de la france et ne tombe
pas bien entendu dans le cas de
l'ensemble des ministres qui eux doivent
faire un effort d'économie et qui doit
se traduire en termes de solidarité
non ce n'était pas l'avis du secrétaire
général du rpr jacques toubon qui
étaient ici à votre place il ya quelques
temps la campagne électorale considéré
que le l'utiliser de l'utilisation du
concorde était excessive trois minutes
de retour en arrière et puis après on
aborde d'autres problèmes sur l' affaire
libyenne
on a dit mais je suis incapable de
savoir si c'est la réalité on a dit que
dans les contacts qui ont eu lieu entre
le présent la république d'une part vous
même d'autre part avec des envoyés
américains le président la république
s'était montré beaucoup plus ferme que
vous à l'égard de la libye et avait même
dit aux américains
il faudrait vraiment régler une fois
pour toutes le problème qu'a défi skis à
ce décalage entre lui et vous je n'ai
pas de commentaire à faire sur cette
question
monsieur des rois vous imaginez
facilement d'abord parce que ce sont des
problèmes que l'on n'aborde pas dans ce
type d'assemblée et ensuite parce que ce
sont des confidences que je n'ai pas à
faire qu'est ce quelle sanction
la france s'apprête elle à prendre
contre la libye monsieur leroy si
j'avais la faiblesse de vous le dire
quels effets d'éventuelles sanctions
pourraient à l'avant la rothaine ya peu
aussitôt après la réunion des ministres
européens en grande bretagne il ya eu
toute une vague de d'expulsion par
exemple en allemagne aussi mais vous
faire remarquer qu'en france également
quelques années une vague importante
d'expulsion et notamment des expulsions
de diplomates
ce qui n'est pas ce qui est le plus
facile à expulse chacun le sait et mais
c'était pas sa véritable sanction pour
le reste vous comprendrez qu'un chef de
gouvernement responsable ne puisse pas
vous répondre à ce type de questions est
ce que il est envisageable par exemple
ce n'est pas le cas en ce moment mais ça
pourrait se présenter dans les semaines
qui viennent et ce qui est envisageable
qu'à nouveau des pilotes libyens
viennent s'entraîner en france
j'écoutais ce droit il n'y a pas de
pilote libyen qui s'entraîne en france
aujourd'hui non mais il ya quelques mois
c'était le cas
il va de soi que tant qu'il y aura le
moindre doute sur la participation de la
libye
et là c'est le cas aujourd'hui à des
actes de terrorisme
il ne peut pas y avoir de coopération
militaire entre la france et la libye
c'est pas du tout faux ce domaine que se
situent nos produits deux petites
précisions sur le visuel des salariés de
cette chaîne ont lancé l'idée d'un
actionnariat populaire de la télévision
en appelant tous les téléspectateurs à
ceux à acheter des actions pour posséder
en moins au moins en partie antenne 2
qu'est-ce que quel est votre rêve cas au
cas où la carte du réalisation qui
serait décidé quelle est votre réaction
toujours été j'appartiens à une famille
politique on a toujours été favorable au
développement de l'actionnariat
populaire donc sur le rasilamlo
lutterait vous choque pas du tout et
éventuellement vous pourriez encourager
des mesures qui permettraient qui lui
faciliterait yade au gouvernement des
hommes compétents qui étudie ces
questions je préférerais alors jugement
alors moins étonné tout à l'heure parce
que philippe alexandre vous a demandé
s'il y aurait deux chaînes privatiser
vous avez renvoyé aux décisions qu'elle
est vous pour vous proposer le ministre
de la culture et la communication
mais c'est dans le programme rpr udf de
chêne privatiser donc vous auriez pu
répondre aussi oui mais l'objectif c'est
oui naturellement la question je crois
que me posais philippe alexandre c'était
de savoir si la privatisation
interviendra immédiatement et sans délai
là je dis c'est à voir
ce sont des huiles de heredia être pas
tout de suite quoi c'est l'objectif
savez j'ai dit une chose dont vous devez
être bien conscient ne sont pas des
sujets qui pas ce qui intéresse le plus
laid les téléspectateurs
nous avons l'udf et le rpr ont fait ont
élaboré ensemble et défendu ensemble une
plateforme commune de gouvernement
c'est le ciment de notre majorique et de
même que j'ai dit la constitution toute
la constitution rien que la constitution
pendant toute la campagne et j'ai été
heureux que président de la république
prennent d'eux mêmes jeudi la plateforme
toute la plateforme et rien que la place
ça c'est le pacte majoritaire et c'est
ce qui nous donne notre force
le gouvernement n'y a pas fait par
conscience il tient sa légitimité
aujourd'hui de sa majorité et il n'a pas
l'intention je vous le dis tout de suite
de mener une politique différente ou
d'aller tenter de séduire quiconque en
dehors de sa propre majorité dont il est
totalement solidaire dans le débat très
important qu'ils aient lieu en ce moment
à l'assemblée nationale vous avez
expliqué tout à l'heure les raisons qui
vous faisait aller vite
quand nakheel délai comptez vous
utiliser le fameux article 49 alinéa 3
de la constitution qui permet de mettre
un terme et que j'aurai la conviction
que nous sommes passés de la discussion
allo constructive à l'obstruction d'un
ce truc
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas cette
conviction jusqu'à présent le alba et
venir d'un moment à l'autre d'un an
mantallot la conviction avant de
repasser aux problèmes économiques et
sociaux
deux petites précisions politique
lorsque dans le débat de confiance
valéry giscard d'estaing au nom de l'udf
on va parler de la vigilance qu'ils
exerceraient de l'udf exercerait est-ce
que vous avez vu une marque de méfiance
à votre égard non j'ai même vu une
marque de confiance car il est naturel
que les deux grandes formations
politiques ainsi d'ailleurs que les
non-inscrits qui sont avec nous dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons avec
le redressement qui s'imposent
exercent une vigilance permanente sur
l'action du gouvernement ne serait ce
que pour l'aider ne serait ce que pour
lui dire attention et quitta
d'aiguillonner temps en temps j'ai dit à
l'éguille au nez de temps en temps un
gouvernement peut bien entendu se
laisser aller tout d'un coup à être un
peu coupé de l'opinion publique
les parlementaires ressentent
quotidiennement ou hebdomadairement dans
leur circonscription et donc la
vigilance des mouvements politiques
à partir du moment où elles s'exercent
dans une solidarité qui est à l'évidence
sans faille est un élément important du
dispositif de gouvernement actuel et je
le souhaite pour mon gouvernement est
donc dans le même débat est-ce que vous
avez interprété le vote de confiance par
raymond barre comme une approbation de
votre politique
je n'ai pas préjuger de ce que pense
monsieur raymond barre je me réjouis
simplement que au titre de la solidarité
majoritaire et alors que nous avons
chacun le sait une courte majorité
il se soit associé à cet effort car je
rappelle que nous avons une majorité
très courte ce sont d'ailleurs les plus
solides et c'est pour ça que maintenant
il l'a dit l'escale et de trois ou
quatre voix puisque nous avons une
opposition qui s'affirme de plus en plus
clairement comme étant formée du parti
communiste du parti socialiste et du
front national
tu pas sûr que tous les électeurs du
front national avait tout à fait compris
ça lorsqu'ils ont voté pour ces
candidats mais enfin c'est ainsi et
c'est comme ça ça prend une majorité qui
est d'autant plus solide et solidaire
qu'elle est courte
dernière petite question politique est
ce que vous espérez sur la réforme du
mode de scrutin et particulièrement sur
leur redécoupage de la france des
séquences et rectorales est ce que vous
espérez obtenir un consensus s'est par
exemple l'accord du parti socialiste
tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on ne nous accuse rappaz de
charcutage on vous accusera certainement
non quand on ne fait pas de bol dirons
nous avons pris toutes les dispositions
notamment la création d'une commission
indépendante pour porter un jugement sur
cette affaire nous aurons toutes les
concertations nécessaires et donc je ne
crois pas qu'on pourra nous accuser de
bonne foi de charcutage ça c'est clair
pour le reste naturellement ça ne peut
ne pas plaire à tout le monde mais c'est
un engagement que nous avions pris et
cette nécessaire pour la stabilité de
nos institutions et pour l'idée que nous
nous faisons de la démocratie
c'est-à-dire les liens personnels de
confiance qui doit exister entre un élu
et ses électeurs alors tout à l'heure
vous avez expliqué pourquoi vous aviez
décidé selon votre programme de
supprimer l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes qui frappait bien les plus
favorisés et vous avez aussi tout à leur
dit que vous vous occupiez également des
plus défavorisées puisque le les faibles
revenus pérennes ne paierait plus
d'impôts de façon plus nombreuses ne
paierait plus d'impôts mais entre les
deux entre les plus favorisés il est
moins favorisés qu'est ce que vous
faites
référez-vous toujours notre plateforme
n'est ce pas nous ferons ce que nous
avons dit que nous ferions
mais plus tard tu as plus tard dans le
prochain budget est naturellement comme
nous l'avions dit c'est à dire une
diminution notamment sur le plan fiscal
puisque c'est sur ce plan devront placer
une diminution que nous avons fixés à 8
% de tous les
niveau du barème de l'impôt sur les
revenus ce qui naturellement intéresse
tout particulièrement les tranches
intermédiaires auquel vous faites
allusion
notre idée étant d'ailleurs d'aller à
terme jusqu'à une situation où le niveau
maximum serait de 50 % parce que nous
considérons qu'au delà il y a une espèce
de deux rapts qui décourage l'esprit
d'initiative et qui explique aussi le
caractère timoré de d'un certain nombre
de gens dans notre pays notamment des
cadres partir du moment où ils ont le
sentiment que un effort supplémentaire
ne leur rapporte pratiquement rien alors
ils ne le font pas parce que ça comporte
toujours un risque
donc il ne faut pas prendre aux gens
plus de la moitié de ce qu'il gagne
concerne le chômage vous avez placé
comme priorité des priorités le chômage
des jeunes
il ya une inquiétude qui se manifestent
c'est vrai que vous accordez aux
entreprises un certain nombre de
davantage si elles embauchent des jeunes
il ya une inquiétude le donge entendu
parlé plusieurs fois ces jours ci est ce
que les entreprises ne vont pas être
incités à licencier des gens d'âge
intermédiaire pour embaucher des jeunes
parce qu'elle y gagneront je voudrais
revenir d'abord sur un boulevard du roi
vous avez dit je n'ai la priorité n'est
pas l'emploi des jeunes une priorité du
gouvernement c'est la lutte contre le
chômage
il ya trois millions de chômeurs
aujourd'hui 40 % moins de 25 ans ce
n'est pas tolérable et donc il faut tout
faire tout faire ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire créer des emplois notamment
pour les jeunes mais aussi pour les
autres
je crée des emplois sait les créer au
seul endroit où il se trouve réellement
c'est à dire dans les entreprises d'où
l'ensemble des mesures et christ quant à
aux plans d'emploi des jeunes que nous
avons mis au point
je ne veux pas rentrer dans son détail
parce que ce sont des choses un peu
complexe mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que l'hypothèse que vous évoquez
n'est pas techniquement possible
pourtant vous allez levé l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement c'est à
dire que le chef d'entreprise aura la
faculté
qu'est ce qui l'empêchera de risation
administrative de licenciement albert
dubois
c'est un mythe on en a beaucoup parlé
pendant la campagne électorale y compris
il faut oui nous y compris moi est
encore sujet vous souvenir lors de mon
dernier passage dans le pré missions
plus il faut savoir qu'actuellement dans
le 95 % des cas elle est accordée
il faut savoir qu il désirait garant le
6 mai il faut savoir que les vraies
garanties
ce n'est pas là qu'elle se situe pour
les travailleurs qui risquent d'être
licenciés c'est dans l'accord
contractuel qui existe au sein de
l'entreprise et qui leur donne un
certain nombre de garanties
donc c'est un mythe je voudrais bien que
les français le comprennent alors vous
me direz puisque ce tome et oui pourquoi
il touchait tout simplement surtout que
cette hausse est tout simplement parce
qu'elle a tout simplement parce qu'il a
deux inconvénients
le premier c'est que l'on donne à des
gens
de grande qualité par ailleurs
certainement mais qui n'ont pas la
formation et la compétence pour le faire
et qui sont des inspecteurs du travail
le soin de juger de l'opportunité de
décisions à prendre dans l'entreprise ce
n'est pas leur rôle
ni leur vocation et deuxièmement parce
que qu'on le veuille ou non la plupart
des responsables des petites moyennes
entreprises se disent mais bien sûr on
le donne enfin on nous le dit mais est
ce que c'est bien vrai alors si nous
embauchons et puis que demain nous ayons
un problème est ce que nous aurons
l'autorisation cette fameuse
autorisation
cela crée une espèce d'inhibition en
espèces de 2 de blocages psychologiques
s'attend à passer à la télévision il ya
quelque temps se tint dustrit elle je
crois de troyes en champagne qui avait
49 employés c'est un réflexe de la même
nature
j'avais vu les effets de ce qu'avait 49
employés et qui avait des commandes
considérable qui le donne et en sous
traitance à son collègue
un de ses collègues espagnols parce
qu'elle ait pas d'autres français qui
fabriquait ce qu'il fabriquait alors on
a essayé de l'expliquer les journalistes
qui étaient là et ensuite le
représentant du patronat le président du
cnpf lui même si lui ai expliqué ma faim
pas raisonnable vous avez la possibilité
de doubler peut-être de tripler le
nombre de veaux de vos salariés
non non il n'en est pas question je ne
veux pas me mettre dans la situation où
l'on se trouve quand on à 51 salariés
le réflexe de se discuter etc
il existe vous avez un très grand nombre
d'employeurs aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont
pas tous des experts en droit du travail
en droit social droit économique et qui
s'imagine que s'il embauche
ils ne pourront pas licenciés s'ils ont
une baisse de leur taux de charge qui
s'imaginent que s'ils franchissent le
seuil des 9 ou des dix employés ou des
49 employés
il va leur arriver tellement de
difficultés de problèmes de contraintes
nouvelles que tout mais pas ça et bien
cette situation stérilise l'initiative
paralyse l'investissement et empêche
l'emploi de se développer il faut tout
changer
et ces mesures qui quand elles ont été
prises pouvaient être considérées comme
des mesures de progrès social que des
mesures qui qui protégeait les
travailleurs aujourd'hui se sont
retournés contre ce qu'elles prétendent
ils font des leurs ne rentre pas dans le
détail la cnil mais voilà si un petit
détail même qu'il était trop de détails
non vous et moi c'est la question que je
vous pose sur l'autorisation du service
de licenciements sur la suppression des
seuils
est-ce que ça s'appliquera à toutes les
entreprises le verrai quand le projet de
loi savons actuellement une élaboration
de ces textes au sein du gouvernement
nous déposerons ces projets doit très
prochainement vous verrez à ce moment
inutile de vous dire que nous ne prenons
pas ces mesures de façon autoritaire
qu'il ya actuellement au sein du
gouvernement à l'initiative du ministre
des affaires sociales une concertation
je dirais pratiquement permanente avec
les responsables des syndicats des
organisations professionnelles et c'est
au terme de cette concertation que les
textes seront élaborés mèze
il est clair qu'il faut supprimer ces
effets de serre et qu'il faut supprimer
ces autorisations
ça ne change rien pour la garantie des
travailleurs auxquels elles sont censé
s'appliquer mais ça change book beaucoup
sur le plan psychologique
dans le cas d'une politique de création
d'emplois de relance de l'activité
artisanale commerciale industrielle lee
râle et ce que nous voulons nous
aujourd'hui je le répète c'est créer des
emplois et de l'activité avant les
élections certains utilisé l'expression
ça va être une révolution libérale est
ce que c'est aujourd'hui une révolution
libérale ou est ce que c'est une
évolution libérale prudente vous de
juger juger c'est le retour plus
exactement c'est la promotion d'une
société où les libertés sont plus
respectés qu'elle ne l'était dans le
passé une vieille tradition nationale
française qui date de plusieurs siècles
et qui veut que l'état s'arroge des
pouvoirs parfois excessives au détriment
des libertés des citoyens
et puis nous sommes arrivés à un moment
de notre histoire où ceux ci devient
paralysant et où ceux ci risque de nous
entraîner dans la dans un processus de
décadence et on le voit aujourd'hui et
donc il faut sortir de cela et notamment
après l'expérience socialiste
c'est ce que nous faisons alors qualifié
le comme vous voulez c'est la promotion
d'une société où chacun prend plus de
liberté et de responsabilité
dernière question albert dernière et
justement il est évident que beaucoup
grande partie de l'opinion attendait des
mesures sur la sécurité il y en a un
certain nombre qui ont été annoncés
aujourd'hui
bon ces mesures elles seront
certainement approuvé par une majorité
elles peuvent susciter aussi l'une ou
l'autre inquiétude
je prends un seul exemple cette fameuse
carte d'identité un falsifiable qui en
principe est une très bonne chose mais
avec les techniques modernes de puces on
peut intégrer à une carte magnétique
énormément d'informations qui
permettrait par exemple lorsqu'on passe
une frontière de voir passer sa carte
d'identité dans un appareil et que le
passage de frontière soit
automatiquement enregistrées transfert
des ordinateurs mais en mémoire et c'est
avec beaucoup d'autres informations à
côté ils sont les garanties qu'il y
avait il ya une commission qui sape et
qui est présidée d'ailleurs un
journaliste et qui s'appelle
informatique et libertés qui demande et
moi demande sont pas tous bons mais nous
essaierons de les suivre aussi près que
possible c'est pas le problème nous
avons des exigences en matière de
sécurité
et ça passe avant d'autres comptes ce
considérant qu' compris avant le respect
c'est le mondial il est témoin de deux
icônes de revenir y compris avant le
respect de certaines libertés
individuelles mais non sommes pour la
liberté du visuel jeu histoire de puces
bon
permettez-moi de revenir à des choses
importantes vous traitez les broues de
mépris des inquiétudes et non je n'ai
aucun mépris des inquiétudes monsieur du
roi je vous ai dit que nous avons saisi
la commission informatique et libertés
qu'elle est composée de gens tout à fait
thémines ans qui n'ont pas la réputation
d'antan prendre à l'aise avec les droits
de l'homme elle est d'ailleurs présidé
par un journaliste lui-même et miller et
fauve est bon nous avons créé un
secrétaire d'état aux droits de l'homme
précisément pour être bien sûr que dans
les initiatives que nous prenons il y
ait quelqu'un qui est là la capacité le
temps de réflexion qui puisse prendre
les contacts nécessaires pour nous dire
attention là vous fait une bêtise
alors je vous dis tout de suite que nous
sommes tout à fait entourer des
garanties qui nous permettront d'éviter
les difficultés des puces donc c'est pas
le problème et ce que nous voulons
aujourd'hui c'est lutter efficacement
contre le terrorisme contre la
criminalité contre la délinquance et
croyez bien s'en porter la moindre
atteinte ça va de soi aux droits de
l'homme ce que j'ai la tête de quelqu'un
qui veut porter atteinte aux droits de
l'homme
bon c'est pas le problème en revanche ce
que je voudrais c'est que les droits
sociaux soit également mieux respectés
comme je vois qu'on arrive à la fin
jose a aussi en toucher un mot vous êtes
un économiste également monsieur du roi
et vous auriez pu me poser la question
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
combien il était essentiel il décidé à
l'avancé des questions je vais vous
pouvez je vais bien comme ça c'est une
coopération et c'est là qu'on s'y oppose
et là vous à vous mais oui c'est la
cohabitation
je vous ai dit ce qu'il ce qu'elle était
notre de notre obsession en matière
d'emploi et les raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai appelé tous les français à bien
comprendre que ceux qui ont la chance
d'avoir un emploi doivent admettre que
leur problème passe après ceux de ceux
qui n'ont pas non plus et donc il y à un
effort de solidarité à métro cela exige
je voulais dit une deuxième
préoccupation majeur pour le
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui et c'est
celle de l'inflation
nous avons fait un réajustement
monétaire qui était indispensable qui a
parfaitement réussi mais qui était juste
ça veut dire je préfère dire la vérité
aux français
ça veut dire que je n'ai aucune marge de
sécurité
aucune marge de manoeuvre ce qui
signifie que nous devons être
extraordinairement vigilant pour ce qui
concerne la hausse des prix et si nous
avons le moindre dérapage dans ce
domaine nous aurons immédiatement une
hausse des prix supérieure à celle de
nos voisins et donc à nouveau une perte
de possibilité d'exporter et donc une
perte de travail dans notre pays
je vous rappelle que depuis plusieurs
années depuis 4 ou 5 ans chaque année
les parts de marché de notre pays c'est
à dire ce que nous fabriquons ce que
fabriquent nos travailleurs nos
ingénieurs et pied vendu tant à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur du
territoire national diminue par rapport
à ce qui est fabriqué par des étrangers
et c'est extrêmement grave pour un pays
qui avaient été portées par georges
pompidou au troisième rang des nations
exportatrices du monde et où je le
répète près d'un travailleur sur trois
travaillent pour l'exportation
d'où la nécessité impérieuse de ne
prendre aucune mesure aucune initiative
qui puisse se traduire par une hausse
des prix qui serait supérieur chez nous
à celle qu'on enregistre à côté ces
batailles notamment le contrôle des prix
selon ça que nous prenons des
précautions dans la suppression du
contrôle des prix qui est supprimée déjà
par les mesures que nous venons prendre
que nous allons prendre en supprimant
l'ordonance en quasi totalité et qui le
sera totalement avant la fin de l'année
mais je fais un appel solennel
notammentà tous les commerçants parce
que ça c'est très important tous les
prestataires de services pour leur dire
vous allez avoir la liberté des prix
total et dans des conditions qui ne
soient pas réversible c'est à dire qu'on
va supprimer les ordonnances de 45 et
supprimer le l'instrument du contrôle
des prix mais en grâce il faut que vous
jouiez le jeu car si d'aventuré vous
laissiez déraper les prix alors de nous
trouverions dans une situation
extrêmement dangereuse et vous seriez
les premiers à le regretter ensuite
qu'est ce que vous feriez pas ce que
c'est de la situation économique de la
france se dégraderait et leurs chiffres
d'affaires diminuent revo rétablir le
contrôle le deuxième point le troisième
point que je voudrais évoquer monsieur
du roi parce qu'il est plus importante
que
ces petites choses c'est la protection
sociale je croyais que vous me poseriez
la question je vous ai dit que
l'ambition de mon gouvernement
c'est d'assumer une certaine politique
sociale c'est aujourd'hui le problème
la réduction des inégalités qu'on a
laissé se développer
et je ne parle pas des inégalités
culturelles qui se sont tant développés
depuis quelques années cela exige le
maintien de notre protection sociale
depuis 45 les français ont fait un grand
effort ils ont mis en place un système
de protection sociale qui s'appelle
sécurité sociale ils y sont attachés à
juste titre et nous devons tous le
défendre avec énergie
or vous parliez de bilan tout à l'heure
monsieur de virieu que je peux vous dire
hélas c'est que si ce bilan est bien
contestable est difficile dans bien des
domaines qu'il s'agisse situation
monétaire de notre déficit budgétaire de
notre endettement intérieur et extérieur
excessif tout cela peut se rattraper par
la volonté du gouvernement de salut
manquent pas et aussi par l'amélioration
de la confiance ce nous permettra de
faire dans le domaine de la production
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup plus c'est la
dégradation des comptes sociaux
c'est le déficit de la sécurité sociale
là nous arrivons devant une situation
qui elle est vraiment dramatique et je
tiens à le dire à tous les français
nous allons avoir probablement en 1986
entre 20 et 25 milliards de déficit en
87 probablement de l'ordre de 40
milliards de déficit ou je sais bien que
il est difficile de faire ce genre de
prévisions mais la situation est là
l'outil est dégradée de fer sont telles
qu'il devient très fragile la situation
de la france est et le vieillissement
c'est le vieil c'est le fait par
contenant certaines choses aujourd'hui
la dépense croit plus doute que la
recette alors c'est du solide notamment
concrètement c'est dû notamment comme
vous le dit à juste titre au
vieillissement au fait que l'on a donné
la retraite à 60 ans à crédit et sans
prévoir les crédits vous allez revenir
sur cette décision
je n'en veux je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que ce que je voulais c'était
maintenir la protection sociale mais se
pose le problème suivant
et je le dis très clairement je ne
souhaite pas et je ne veux pas augmenter
les cotisations pesant sur les
travailleurs sur les salariés ou sur les
entreprises revenir aux errements du
passé pourquoi parce que c'est la voie
de la facilité et que la facilité c'est
le contraire du redressement et que si
l'on se dit chaque fois qu'on a à faire
face à un problème il suffit d'augmenter
d'un point les cotisations que payent
les salariés ou les entreprises
après tout ils n'ont qu'à payer et puis
nous on se chargera ainsi de trouver les
fonds nécessaires pour permettre la
dépense alors on arrive à la situation
que nous connaissons et qui fait 3
millions de chômeurs parce que à côté de
nous les autres entreprises en allemagne
ailleurs n'ont pas la même politique et
ont su tenir leurs dépens donc je ne
veux pas où je ferai tout pour éviter on
augmente
les quotidiens vous dites il faut
aligner la protection sociale française
sur le niveau de la protection sociale
de nos concurrents et dis donc il faut
faire des économies
ces économies ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire d'abord des économies dans la
gestion l'ensemble de notre système de
protection sociale a un peu dérapé par
rapport à ce qu avez-vous lu s'effondre
il est devenu par trop bureaucratique
il faut donc faire des économies dans la
gestion il est possible que ce ne soit
pas suffisant
et donc il faudra que chacun là aussi
fassent un choix entre un petit
inconvénient personnel pour ceux qui ont
la chance d'avoir une situation un
emploi un travail ou bien d'accepter
pour ce qu'on ne veut surtout se priver
de rien que l'on ne lutte pas
efficacement avec tous nos moyens en
faveur de ceux qui n'ont pas de travail
qui sont les exclus de notre société qui
sont infiniment trop nombreux et qu'ils
finiront par la déstabiliser durablement
ce qui n'est pas accédé acceptable vous
demande raisonnable ou bien vous
annoncer des mesures je n'annonce pas de
mesures doit y avoir une affaire que
nous verrons à la fin de l'année mais je
dis tout de suite que le bilan dont nous
héritons en matière de protection
sociale est un bilan très lourd
c'est le résultat d'une politique qui a
été une politique peu de cigales et que
nous devrons nous en assumer la
responsabilité dans des conditions qui
seront difficiles pour tout le monde et
je préfère qu'on le sache dès maintenant
s'ils aiment aussi important que les
puces non c'est important aussi aussi
c'est important d'écouter y sommes
garanties alors secrétaire d'état
tandis que pour régler tous les
problèmes de sécurité sociale ils se
font dans leur faudra plusieurs états
des terreaux si louis ministre nous
allons maintenant retourner svp pour un
minimum de questions jean louis le scène
par jacques chirac tard oui jacques
chirac voulait revenir sur une question
concernant les otages de beyrouth les
otages d'antenne 2 et les autres
maintenant que vous avez établi des
rapports normaux et permanent avec le
quai d'orsay tu demandes ce
téléspectateur après un mois de
gouvernement
pouvez vous nous faire partager vos
espoirs ou vos craintes à propos de ces
otages en impressionnant téléspectateurs
pose la même question ce soir j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que je ne pouvais pas et
que je ne voulais pas parler les otages
je répète qu'il ne se passe pas de
journée sans que je m'occupe
personnellement de ce propos une autre
question
willis qui est l'avant dernière une
autre question je vous montre le paquet
question fait la même question sur
toutes ces fiches quand annulerez vous
la taxe sur les magnétoscopes vous
demander ça à mon ministre des finances
[Musique]
de réponse personnelle l'an dernier
parce qu'il a prévues dans ce code
enfin dernière question alors pour
revenir aux questions du départ et
auquel vous n'avez pas répondu sur vos
rapports personnels avec le président de
la république en dehors du conseil des
ministres dit ce téléspectateur je vous
repose la même question quand vous
rencontrez tête à tête vous donnez-vous
toujours du monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre votre fiche
contrairement à ce qu'affirment certains
leaders socialistes vous sentez vous
le premier ministre de françois
mitterrand j'appelle toujours le
président par son titre et la réciproque
est vraie et c'est tout à fait naturel
ce n'est pas pour ça que je ris j'avais
spontanément il m'était venue
spontanément une réponse à votre
question ça pourrait d'ailleurs être la
dernière ça fera plaisir à monsieur de
virieu qui est pressé à juste titre je
ne me sens le projet ne sais pas moi qui
suis prêt si c'est le respect que nous
aller dire aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
attendent j'allais dire je me sens le
premier ministre de la france
et puis tout d'un coup ça évoqué chez
moi des souvenirs que qui me conduise à
des souvenirs qu'ils qui se réfère à une
autre émission bien et bien maintenant
pendant que vous parliez monsieur
communiste la sofres a télé son départ
militaire l'échantillon que là
spécialement sélectionnés pour cette
émission est parce que nous avons essayé
de mesurer votre pouvoir de conviction
sur tel ou tel sujet voir si vous avez
réussi à faire changer l'opinion des
gens qui nous regardent ce soir avoue
jérôme jaffré avoue la sofres alors
l'émission de ce soir était
particulièrement intéressante puisque
monsieur chirac avait été l'invité de
l'heure de vérité il ya deux mois et
nous avons donc posé un certain nombre
de questions pour mesurer l'évolution et
il faut le dire tout de suite cette
évolution est très favorable à monsieur
chirac le sentiment de confiance des
français apparaît assez nettement
premier élément l'image personnelle de
monsieur chirac at on une bonne opinion
ou une mauvaise opinion de monsieur
chirac
66% des personnes figurant dans
l'échantillon de la sofres ont une bonne
opinion 29% une mauvaise il y a deux
mois à la fin de l'émission c'était 53 %
de bonnes opinions pour monsieur chirac
38% mauvais
16 13 points de gagner deux français sur
trois donc qu'ils ont une bonne opinion
deuxième élément at on trouvé monsieur
chirac convaincant sur les grands thèmes
qu'il a abordé ce soir là nous avons
posé une série d'éléments l'insécurité
les premières mesures prises par le
gouvernement et le chômage on retrouve
en gros toujours le même pourcentage
entre 49 et 50 4% de convaincant et
toujours en gros le même pourcentage de
style entre 33 et 35 % ce qui est
intéressant c'est sur le chômage
car à la question posée il ya deux mois
sur les moyens de lutter contre le
chômage
il n'y avait que 37% de convaincant il y
en a ce soir 49% donc une attente
nouvelle est née sur le problème du
chômage dernière question
l'action du gouvernement va t-elle dans
la bonne direction ou dans la mauvaise
direction
nous l'avons posée juste avant le début
de l'émission est juste à la fin et là
on voit l'impact propres de l'émission
qui est assez intéressant puisqu'il y
avait 43 % des personnes interrogées en
début d'émission a estimé que l'action
du gouvernement allait dans la bonne
direction
et à la fin de l'émission il y en a
cinquante cinq pour cent je crois qu'on
peut incontestablement parler ce soir
d'un état de grâce pour monsieur chirac
que traduisent ces résultats voilà je ne
vous demande pas de commentaire monsieur
le premier ministre est donc l'heure de
vérité de jacques chirac prochain rendez
vous le mercredi 21 mai invités monsieur
françois léotard ministre de la culture
et de la communication bonsoir
[Musique]